if you're looking for ways to be a
visionary get rid of your limiting
beliefs and have absolute certainty then
this video is for you
most people have goals in life and we
would book think you got to be
goal-oriented that's the first mistake
the beliefs that we have really control
our actions we don't typically go at
things or do things that we believe
we're not good at what sales really is
is the transfer of emotion need
motivation watch the top 10 with belief
nation what's up it's Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see explode out onto
the world so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a man who once sold twenty thousand
dollars worth of ice cream and a summer
at the beach and wanted to become a
dentist to actually becoming the wolf of
Wall Street and a motivational speaker
he's Jordan Belfort and here's my take
on his top ten rules a success volume to
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be a visionary
most people have goals in life and we
would Brooke think you got to be
goal-oriented that's the first mistake
yes you need goals but there's something
far beyond goals which is what all
successful people have and that's a
vision it's a vision for the future see
the here's it is you see things as they
are but not worse than they are
yeah which is what a lot of people do
yeah they say oh it's so terrible they
tell themselves this wild story about
why they can't take action and in truth
the story they tell themselves is
exactly what holds them back from being
successful okay it's that bull story
that stops from acting like and they're
all just some of the economy and they
play the blame game they complain they
justify and it stops them from moving
forward so see things as they are not
worse than they are you know and then
see them better than they are
yeah and make them that way look at a
Gandhi right he survived hunger strikes
United the country not close he had a
gold for free and yet he had a vision of
a free India Nelson Mandela all those
years in jail on vision yeah Richard
Branson was a friend of mine who I know
he sponsors me my speaking to her he's a
visionary Bill Gates they're all
visionaries and the best example
consider where in Hollywood is a guy
like James Cameron now here's the trap
James Cameron is probably the greatest
visionary of all time in filmmaking that
we do a great Darren he was a food on
Diane Sawyer and they asked him a
question of what do you owe your success
to and what he said was this I said
really really high goals so even if I
fall short I'm still doing great and
people thought that was pretty profound
and I actually believe in that too it's
not true though see what's happening is
this James Cameron is that goal center
he's a visionary he just doesn't realize
because he's running unconscious
strategy himself you said that I said
James camels are really just the goals
your vision for avatar he'd say oh of
course I will didn't get all excited me
tell you how nothing was gonna stop him
from making this movie the fact that it
took ten years and ran 200 million over
budget he put money in himself or that's
not what goal setters do bowl setters
will set a goal get tough and they
abandon it and I can't overemphasize
that distinction that's number one whose
vision rule number two my
personal favorite is get rid of limiting
beliefs second thing is your beliefs
essentially the beliefs that you hold
about yourself about your capabilities
about money whether you'll believe said
attract money to you or that repel money
but that you have beliefs that allow you
to move through barriers and obstacles
or beliefs that cause you to shy away
from Batteries and obstacles and the
beliefs that we have really control our
actions we don't typically go at things
or do things that we believe we're not
good at
we don't take actions everything we're
gonna fail we shy away and then of
course we don't say that we're scared we
come up with the story so the sort of
these negative these limiting beliefs
Institute instigate they're telling the
bully stories to ourselves right and it
holds us back from success so the idea
is that is to understand what your
horror limiting beliefs are and then to
actually break those beliefs and you can
do that's not that difficult to do it do
it in a seminar setting you break the
limiting beliefs and you essentially
empower somebody by helping them install
their own beliefs in themselves those
your beliefs are malleable you can
change them so the idea is to
essentially retrofit your beliefs to
serve you and your outcomes in the case
of entrepreneurs is tough and money is
not the root of all evil that building
the business is possible that I can
learn whatever any noble sort of beliefs
rule number three is learn how to
influence and persuade Warren Buffett
was doing the speech of Bill Gates about
me ten years ago and he was asked by a
college student what can we do as
students to make ourselves more valuable
in the workplace so you think Warren
Buffett would say learn how to pick
stocks or investments you know whatever
you would say not what he says he says
go out and take a course in sales and
codification there he did Dale Carnegie
change his life there you go now that
point because he took they said I took
Dale Kearney changement without that you
don't he'd be without that course yeah
he'd be the richest money manager in
Omaha Nebraska then no one ever heard of
yeah Annie met his wife that way the
loves of life because without the
ability to influence and persuade yeah
okay you can't put yourself out there
into the
world and be known for what you really
are rule number four is manage your
state I'm gonna angle pissed off
negative unruhe social state you can't
do anything well you've met one of those
days for instance where everything
you're doing you're like I can't believe
I said that I can't believe I did that
I'm such a fool right yeah that day
we've all had that day yeah
next day similar situation you're like
wow you know that was me I did a really
great job right you were perfect so one
day you're brilliant next day same
situation you're brutal that's not
talent that's not ability that's the
state that you're in so the key to
success is not just a to have your
vision but to be able to manage the way
you feel in the moment now if you're a
parent what's the most resourceful state
patience if you're a businessman looking
to make money on Wall Street it's
probably certainty yeah more courage
because fear is the worst emotion of all
for being a traitor on Wall Street so
every business has different states that
you need to master now in most
businesses in matters of wealth is
straight three states that you need to
master feel the trigger and a moment's
notice and it's easy to do what you
learn how we're just gonna teach people
okay and number one is certainty to be
certain about what you're doing the
second one is clarity to be clear it's
not to be overwhelmed with the obvious
will be overwhelmed and the third is
courage is to have a conviction to know
that you might not be right all the time
but you're gonna got to let fear stop
because if there's one distinction that
between the wealthy people of the world
and the poor people of the world is that
wealthy people act in the face of fear
while poor people run away from favorite
rule number five is do what you love
choose something that you do that you
love that you're passionate about and
that's like a cliche but it's true you
know there's many many ways to make
money in this world this it's easy to
get rich it's not quite so easy it's one
of the best-kept secrets in the world
it's easy to make a lot of money but you
can make money in ways that you know are
easy and fun
spotting your supervisors lucrative fun
right and you can make money in ways
that are real pain in the ass but it's
hard work it doesn't
arey doesn't inspire so number one is
choose something that's gonna feed your
spirits and feed your soul inspire you
rule number six have absolute certainty
what sales really is is the transfer of
emotion that's what's happening when you
sell you're transferring emotion and the
primary emotion that you're transferring
is the emotion of certainty in other
words watch this you as a salesman when
you enter the encounter you have to be
absolutely certain that your product is
the best make sense it's gonna give them
the best benefits out there the best
value proposition and so forth and you
are in this state of absolute certainty
so imagine now we have a continuum of
certainty a line of certainty so we have
this line of certainty and on one side
of the equation we have it's called a1
and the other side we have a 10 so what
10 represents a state of absolute
certainty meaning your prompt is the
best thing since sliced bread it's gonna
give them exactly what they want benefit
wise it's the best deal for the money's
gonna make them feel the whole thing
right it is just absolutely awesome
that's a 10 on the certain skill it is
great the best thing since sliced bread
and on the other end of the spectrum you
have what's called a1 right which is
it's the worst piece of [ __ ] in the
world right it's crap
right your prompt is terrible it's not
gonna work
okay the benefits don't match up what
they need it's overpriced I didn't want
to be near this piece of crap because I
just feel stupid even buying it or even
thinking about buying it that's a 1
right so here's the first thing you need
to understand that the moment you open
up your mouth to speak as a sales when
you start a sale the question is this
where is the average prospect the person
you're trying to sell to where are they
on the certainty scale at the beginning
anyone know where are they who the [ __ ]
knows
you must be in this state of absolute
certainty because what's happening is
this what you're doing when you're
selling is everything that you say
everything that you do every tonality
use every gesture you make every
document you hand them every phrase that
comes out of your mouth
are all designed to do one simple thing
to essentially raise the prospects level
of certainty to as close to his 10 as it
possible that's what you're doing your
the words that you say the the
presentation that you make the tonality
that you use every any document you in
sales aids whatever it might be is all
designed to take them from where they
are on the certainty scale and move to
as close to where you are as possible
essentially you're transferring your
white-hot certainty to souls that a
cooler level at a lower level of
certainty it's almost like this first
law or so I think it's actually the
second law of thermodynamics in physics
right under you study physics energy
always flows from hot to cold not the
other way around so you need to be this
white-hot level of certainty it's
exerting out of you every pore that you
have and we know what certainty feels
like in sounds like we intuitively know
as salespeople and our prospects though
as well we know when someone sounds
certain and they have confidence in
their enthusiastic we know what that
looks like feels like it sounds like
rule number seven is learn new skills
people don't realize how much of success
is not an accent it's like it's about
people have these extraordinary skills
and they take action yeah so I'm a big
believer in learning skills like you
wrote read my first book right yes well
when I first tried to write I was a
terrible writer I taught myself to write
by woeful Wall Street was your first
book yes and I wrote before I couldn't
my first try tries to tell right
how many copies have sold a millions of
copies right Wow so so how do I write
wolf of Wall Street myself without a
ghost right
I picked up a book called bonfire in the
vanities and started reading it Tom
Wolfe and free of reading right yeah and
as soon as I started reading I'm like oh
my god this guy's the best writer in the
world I want to write like that and I
used his book like a textbook I took out
my highlighter and I broke down his
strategy for writing and I practiced
before I wrote the book I said let me
first teach myself the skill to write
like Tom Wolfe and that's what I did I
spent about six or seven months with 18
hours a day not really
oh yes to the part I could recite the
whole book verbatim okay closely so the
point is is that I learnt how to
introduce characters almost like it was
a mentor the book was your mentor it had
my model yeah I mean I wrap it up with
tons of responses to get made sense go
to the drug use right so I I know but I
use those mmm I was reviewing the New
York Times I said the book sounds like
hunt the rest Thompson and Tom wolf so
it was amazing right then I accomplished
my mission and made her turn myself into
a writer rule number eight is manage
your standards on some levels your
standard which is really like a
thermostat it's we gonna end up now your
standards is not a constant we like this
is my standard if you have a standard in
any given moment in time you'll be
stopped the above your standard it's
like the lawyer standing but that
standard really dictates sort of where
you end up over the long term
so there's many people out there for
instance that you know they have stand
that they need to make $200,000 a year
so they make $200,000 a year because
what happens when they go over that hey
back off other people understanding they
make two million you know I won't sell
make two million right those will end up
the two million so the idea is that to
first realize what is my standard and
does my standard serve my outcome is my
skin it too low is my standard and
reasonable and so there's any you know
conflict that this dissonance between
where you want to go what your actual
standard is then you need to either
raise your standard or sometimes even it
could be lowering of financial standard
if it's if it's corrupting the rest of
your life but typically what we find is
that people have financial stands that
are really not serving their old it low
they could raise them up rule number
nine is hustle I was a born entrepreneur
that's right
exited my mother's womb when I was eight
years old I was delivering papers
door-to-door knocking on doors expanding
the paper out
I was 12 years old I was shoveling
driveways after snowstorms in New York I
made 20 bucks a driveway after a big
snowstorm
I hit it big for the first time when I
was 16 selling Isis on the beach blanket
- blanket the blanket night by that's
how it started and after that I was
hiring people to come working at little
I'd twelve year old kids selling puka
shell necklaces for my mother was
buttering bagels in the morning and that
was really the way I always was was you
know moving towards life yeah I was just
you know always wanted to make money and
rule number ten the last one before the
bonuses is always be prepared you ended
up at this firm
it was oak what was it oh crap okhta
little firm called the Investor Center
which is a penny stock firm right and
that was where I you know it was really
the first night I ever sold stock and I
became the top broker the first day just
broke all the records really in the
first day you broke all the right the
first day yeah yeah so you're a born do
you think you're a born salesman yeah
for sure I am open and there are people
out there all born closers one salesman
far if you would do there are some when
that really means that what does it mean
to be a born salesman what it means is
that you're actually running the
strategy automatically inside you're
really good you're still following this
script but it comes natural
automatically so you but you don't
realize it but you are following a
certain protocol that gets you to the
same outcome every time so that's really
what it born closers so for those people
watching that our entrepreneurs want to
learn sales what did you do in that
first day that you basically became a
top sales in like was there we're gonna
talk more about your whole sales
straight-line formula but first day you
didn't have time to implement a whole
script what do you do that most people
don't do is it your tonality that's one
of the things body language tonality
taking people through
features not just features but benefits
according I think you did that first day
well in fact I see one of the
interesting things you say you would
you'd have time to put the other scripts
in fact I did oh you did oh yeah day one
I took three hours to write one see I
would never this is something
interesting thing had many years layers
is relevant is that I was tested by some
psychologists not my ability to close
they put me through a whole battery of
these weird s and
them was a mock sale where I had to
close someone in a investment type of
situation it was being filled was there
like sell me this pen
they handed me a little sort of us some
information on the dairy industry and I
have to then convince someone to open up
an account at a firm to manage the money
for the dairy industry right okay so
they handy about about 10 12 pages of
information right and they said take as
much time as you want and you know just
I said let's see you close this guy
right so I start reading I'm reading it
and I'm reading right I start writing
down my thoughts now thirty minutes
later they knock on the door I'm like
yeah said give me more time yeah just
give me another 30 bits I said okay no
problem
30 minutes goes by they come back I said
just me another 20 minutes they said no
problem take 20 more minutes I said give
me 15 more minutes right anyway after
about two hours I said I'm ready and I
had wrote myself a really really not an
exact script but pretty close to a
really killer script with so if you know
how I would actually engineer the sail
from storm there's so many stocks no
canals recent many oh really
okay this is right is relevant now this
is in nineteen it's like I think the
2010 at this Apple okay with
psychologists being Phil okay this is
the later son died he was an actor and
he was supposed to be the CEO of a dairy
company and I was supposed to close him
so we go through this whole thing I
introduced myself and I we go for this
back and forth back and forth and
they're filming the whole thing and
after about 15 minutes the guy just he's
like okay fine I'll open up an account
and he starts laughing his ass off so
I'm like what's so funny
psychologists come and they say we told
him under no circumstances should he say
yes yeah within 15 minutes yet no he
said yes I don't get it he said I said
well you don't want I got the guy into a
situation did it make sense to say no he
said well here's the weird thing we've
tested a hundred other people in sales
and no one ever spent more than five
minutes reading the material huh you
spent so apparation it's some simple
fundamental teach equip are the straight
line is about strategic preparation
meeting that you don't you know what was
my overriding concept is every sales the
same right yes and that would seem to be
counterintuitive yes because everyone
has different needs different belief
systems right different outcomes real
but the truth is that every sale is the
same yes and I'll explain that led bit
later on in the interview but it's star
with your ability to essentially make an
airtight case to someone yes on both
illogical and the notion right yeah
about you know essentially why you're
right you could want them to do whatever
you want them to why does it make sense
right and it's got to be an airtight
case and then you have to be able to
also accomplish other things as well so
there's two ways to go about that one is
still wing it which you could might be
able to do if you're really really great
or you can write it down plan it out I
mean the second one is where you really
start to bring your averages of
tremendous ease oh I'm a big believer in
strategic preparation so Jordan always
has a lot of great things to say a lot
of which I agree with it's why we've
been able to do two volumes of his top
ten rules to success my personal
favorite is rule number two get rid of
limiting personal beliefs because every
major growth that I've seen in my
business has come from me squashing a
limiting belief in my very first
business I was 19 years old and I didn't
have a science degree and I sucked the
computers and I was selling
biotechnology scientific software to
people who are three times my age in
some cases who had multiple PhDs and I
thought they won't listen to me and it
took me a year to really figure that out
that all they cared about was that I
could provide value not what my
background was not how old I was and so
the story that I was telling myself as
to why I couldn't do something was
really limiting me and every major
breakthrough that I made in my business
has been because I broke through
something here something inside myself
and then I carried that forward I've
raised my standards I had new belief
systems and I can go conquer new
mountains and still you might think that
I've accomplished a lot with my youtube
and my businesses but I could still be
doing a lot more and the thing that's
holding me back is another set of
limiting beliefs so I need to find those
crush those and move on to the next step
and so I love the message hopefully you
guys did too rule number two is my
personal favorite I want to know from
you guys do you agree Israel MOTU the
best in this video or is the one that
hit you harder leaving the comments
below I'm really curious if I know
now I made this video because crazy
chicken penguin asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next check out the
link in the description to the request
line and you can go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Randy Pearce Randy thank you so much man
for picking up a copy of my new book the
top ten rules a success and taking that
picture and sending it in I really
appreciate it man and I hope you're
enjoying the book so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're on where it is
much love I'll see you soon
and marketing is about you know bringing
massive numbers of people into your
sales funnel to attract people
but not just any people tracked
qualified people you know how do you
identify your target market what are the
strategies that allow you to really have
a message to market-match
to contact a lot of people at once in a
cost-effective manner and attractive to
whatever it is whether it's your landing
page an incoming poll but it doesn't
have to walk into your store whatever
your business is but without the
marketing the equation you know you'll
be selling and selling and suddenly it's
all cold so the highest level companies
that succeed they have not just the
great sales program they have a great
marketing program as well let's focus on
money for a second because especially
this time the economy everyone's
interested in making more money securing
the future for not just themselves the
families and the children and this is
important people say you know money
doesn't matter I'm like oh so you're
broke
well that's it so it tells you they're
broke I never had any money because just
look at it like this just imagine if you
said that your wife wasn't that
important how long would she stick
around
yeah not too long right money is
important money is not gonna make you
happy
nah but an absence of money could buy
you an awful lot of misery so I look at
money as this it's a problem needs to be
solved yeah and here's another
distinction which I think everyone
should really key into because this
misconception that you know and selling
money might be evil here's the deal
there's no amount of poverty that you
can have in your life that can make one
of the person wealthy no amount of
misery that you can have in your life
that can make one of the person happy
there's no amount of sickness in your
life that can make one of the person
healthy if you want to make the world a
happier healthier wealthier place then
you get as much of those gifts you can't
do yourself and then spread it around
there are certain commonalities to all
human beings right when it comes to
rapport building into report both in a
business setting and a personal setting
but it really boils down to two things
number one that you care yes that in
business you're not just there to make a
sale to earn a commission you actually
care about the person and you wanted to
get the outcome they're looking for
that's number one and number two is that
um just like you we and not like
everything you like I like that's
disingenuous bull right like you know
you see a fish roll oh my god
you like to fish on you slot both like
Michael Scott back off that's ridiculous
right I'm talking about something very
different talking about that you speak
at the same general pace they do you
hope that when they answer a question
AHA yeah mm oh the interest that you say
yeah I get it we're on the same page and
it's very it's almost below the surface
because here's the thing imagine you
know you just meet a Salesman your
prospect right and the salesman looks at
you and says you know I really care
about you and okay you want to make the
warranty in the beginning there's no
words you can say to say I care about
you all the time of course you give
great service you have a relation yes
you can tell us what I care and I've
proved that but in an initial contact
that's so disingenuous oh yes how do you
get that across to tonality and body
language that's how you do it yep the
most important word ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you that sums you Apple
so it would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]